From dragon flame foreshadowing to easter
eggs revealing how fan favourite fairies Tecna
and Flora will appear, Fate: The Winx Saga
has a stack of secrets hidden in every episode.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm uncovering all the magical details you
might have missed in the first season of Netflix's
live-action adaptation of Winx Club,
including the secret twist that Ms Dowling's
fate in the finale may not be what it seems.
We will of course be talking spoilers, so
take care.
Although the new series initially downplays
fans' expectations of getting to see the Winx
with fairy wings..
"Just kinda bummed I didn't see a single pair
of wings."
"Well, we had wings in the past.
As we've evolved, transformation magic has
been lost."
..the red butterfly on the lamp that Bloom
brings with her to Alfea is a clever bit of
foreshadowing to her big transformation in
the finale when she sprouts wings as she unleashes
the power of the dragon flame inside her.
And that scene pays homage to elements of
Bloom's original Winx Club transformation,
albeit with some notable differences.
The fire that licks around her as she goes
full fairy is similar to the animation, although
in Winx Club the fire wrapping around Bloom
is accompanied by a costume change.
If you're disappointed by the Netflix show's
lack of costume change, remember that Bloom
has only just discovered the Dragon Flame,
and as her powers grow in the future, her
transformations may well become bigger and
better.
And hopefully, the other Winx Suite members
will also get wings too like in the animated
show.
By the way, in the original Winx Club, the
Dragon Flame also gave Bloom healing abilities,
including the time she was able to save Sky
after a fatal attack;
and it appears that in Fate, Bloom has also
acquired a similar ability when she heals
a cut on Sky's face just by touching it.
Another big moment from the final episode
comes when Rosalind abruptly kills Farah with
her magic by snapping her neck.
This was an unexpected and shocking moment,
but also a somewhat underwhelming way for
a powerful fairy like Ms Dowling to exit the
show.
If you're a Farah fan though, you can take
solace in the subtle hint you might have missed
in the scene that suggests the former headmistress
may still be alive.
Notice how Farah's eyes light up just before
Rosalind attacks her, suggesting she may be
drawing on her own magic to protect herself
against a likely attack from her nemesis.
Farah's dead body may simply be an illusion
she's cast to fool Rosalind, like many of
the other illusions we've seen fairies cast
in the show.
And if you're at all sceptical, then just
remember that Sky's father Andreas was brought
back from the dead despite the seemingly lethal
blow that Silva landed on him.
And let's not forget that handy healing power
that Bloom has either.
The casting of Terra and Musa has been problematic
given how it erased both Latin and Asian representation
in the new series, making this show's main
cast less diverse than the original noughties
animation.
There is, however, a tease to a potential
resolution for fans disappointed at the lack
of Flora in the series when Terra reveals
some more details about her family to Musa.
"I've got this cousin called Flora, and my
mum's called Rose."
The Flora namedrop hopefully means that the
OG Winx Club nature fairy who was modelled
on Jennifer Lopez will be introduced in a
future season.
Another missing founding fairy from the animated
series is Tecna, the fairy of technology.
However, there's a clue in the first season
that might have revealed her or somebody closely
related to her.
In the third episode, when Bloom is studying
some of the Alfea yearbooks, the camera deliberately
goes in close on one of the pages, lingering
on it for several seconds.
Interestingly, one of the names on the page,
"Devon Walker", is described as a Science
Fair winner.
It looks like this description refers to this
former alumna of Alfea here, who also appears
in the centre of this group photo, and who
Bloom commented was a "Farah Fawcett" lookalike
when she saw her in a school photo on one
of the walls.
The show seems to be calling attention to
this character, and the fact that she was
particularly skilled at science could imply
that this is Tecna, or if not Tecna herself,
then someone related to her, for example,
her mother.
Of course, it's possible that this is just
a tease to a brand new original character
that will be introduced later on, but either
way it seems likely she will have some significance
to a future storyline.
Also mentioned on the page is somebody called
"Sparta West 'Red'" and if you've any theories
about Tecna or either of these two characters,
comment below!
When Bloom meets Rosalind for the first time,
the show seems to imply that the voices Bloom
has been hearing calling to her have been
Rosalind's all along.
[whispering] Hello, Bloom.
However, if you go back and listen to the
ghostly voices that Bloom originally heard
calling to her, they sound quite different
to Rosalind's voice.
[whispering voices] Bloom, Bloom..
These may actually be a hint and a tease to
Daphne who was a type of spirit guardian and
sister to Bloom in Winx Club.
Similar to the mysterious voice calling to
Bloom in the new show, Daphne's ghost also
called to Bloom in Winx Club to come and find
her.
"I'm all around you Bloom.
I'm within you Bloom.
I'll show you."
"Woh!
Daphne!"
Daphne was also once a guardian of the Dragon
Flame and so if she appears in the show, she'll
likely have a part to play in helping Bloom
learn about that power.
Alfea's resident bad girl Beatrix may be an
air fairy, however, her name is a reference
to the villainous Trix sisters from Winx Club,
who were witches.
Beatrix also says that she's from Aster Dell,
which was apparently a village of Blood Witches,
suggesting it's possible that Beatrix will
actually turn out to be a witch in the show,
rather than a fairy.
And although Beatrix appears to combine various
attributes of the three OG Trix, Icy, Darcy
and Stormy, it wouldn't surprise me if she
discovers she has a couple of villainous sisters
or relations in a future season.
And if you were ever in any doubt that bad
boy Riven would end up joining Beatrix on
the Dark Side, the infamous book on his desk
is a dead giveaway.
The overall theme of "The Prince" by Machiavelli,
that it's justifiable to act in an immoral
way in order to achieve political goals,
also points to some of the themes in the first
season such as Rosalind lying about evacuating
Aster Dell so she could destroy the Blood
Witches living there as well as the Burned
Ones.
Another little detail about Riven you might
have missed comes in the final episode when
he meets Rosalind for the first time.
Notice how both his and Dale's eyes light
up as she enters the room, which could suggest
that they have some latent magical abilities,
or the way that Rosalind's eyes glowed at
the same time could imply that she's cast
a spell on them to pull them over to her side
as she takes control over the school.
There's a hint that we could see some of the
more interesting powers Aisha had in the animated
series in Fate.
For clues, let's take a look at the scene
where Farah is explaining to Aisha about her
water-based powers.
"A mass of water, is persistent and reliable.
A drop of water..
is unpredictable.
Vague.
Amorphous.
Can you isolate it?
Can you maintain that which fights form?"
Farah's description of water as "amorphous"
could be a reference to "Morphix", the name
of Aisha's power source in Winx Club and a
magical, malleable substance which the fairy
can create by rearranging water molecules.
"Morphix Cloud!"
I'm not sure whether the Fate showrunners
will go there, but there were some really
cool things like Aisha's Morphix Surfboard
that could be awesome to see in live action.
"Morphix Surfboard!"
By the way, there's also a hint in Fate that
Aisha might be a princess like she is in Winx
Club when Stella tells Bloom to ask Aisha
about what it means to lose a Crown Jewel.
"That might not mean much to a First Worlder.
Feel free to ask your suite-mate how big of
a screw-up that is."
"Almost as big as giving it to her in the
first place."
Another change from Winx Club is Musa being
a mind fairy rather than a fairy of music.
There are, however, a few references in the
new series to her musical background in the
animation, from the DJ poster on the wall
by her bed,
to how she listens to music on her headphones
whenever she wants to drown out reading other
people's emotions, to the fact that she tells
Riven she was once a dancer.
"I wouldn't expect a mind fairy to have such
good moves."
"I used to be a dancer."
Fashion was a huge part of Winx Club and fans
of that aspect of the OG show will likely
be disappointed with the costuming on Fate.
There is perhaps a small nod to Winx Club
fashion though when Bloom is surprised at
how often Stella changes her clothes each
day.
"So, a casual thing you're changing for?"
"People have seen me in this outfit already.
They'll expect something different.
People expect you to wear multiple outfits
a day?"
And there's another neat little homage to
the OG series when Bloom reveals that she
was born in 2004, a reference to how Winx
Club first premiered on Italian TV in that
year.
And in case you didn't know, Abigail Cowen
who plays Bloom also starred in Netflix's
Chilling Adventures of Sabrina as one of the
three Weird Sisters,
and if you're fan of that show, check out
my video with all the best easter eggs and
things you missed in the final season of Sabrina.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So what did you think of Fate: The Winx Saga,
and how it changed from the animated series?
And do you have any theories on what you'd
like to see in Season 2?
Leave all your thoughts and comments down
below.
And if you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up
is hugely appreciated!
Tap left for my next Netflix video including
a full breakdown of the Sabrina series finale
and a potential Part 5, or tap right for something
else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!